[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's 800 463 720
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor john ross
hello friends how about an amazing fact
well it isn't well known that bats fly
using sonar they emit high frequency
sounds which the human ear cannot hear
these returning echoes of sound places
sound print pictures in their minds
using this technique a bat can catch a
tiny fast flying insect the calls of the
bat are very loud so loud in fact that
if we could hear them they would hurt
our ears
but wait if it is necessary for the bat
to make such a loud sound in order to
have its echo back from a distant object
how can the bat possibly hear the echo
with its ears
in the midst of all of the racket that
it's making with its mouth
and to make matters worse
the bat's ears are so sensitive that
just a few of its screams would quickly
definite
that is except for a tiny muscle in the
middle ear of the bat
it is attached to one of three tiny
bones which transmit the vibrations of
the eardrum to the tubular organ in the
skull that converts them to nerve
signals sent to the brain
just as each screen is on the verge of
being emitted this muscle instantly
pulls back that bone so that it does not
transmit sound from the outer ear to the
inner ear
the eardrum is momentarily disconnected
then after the scream is ended the
muscle relaxes and the bone moves back
into place
and the faint echo of the sound can be
heard
the faster these sounds are omitted
the more up-to-date information the
battle receive
the faster these sounds of course is
necessary if the bat is trying to fly
through the curves of a cave or flying
amongst the branches of the forest
some bats can send up to 200 quick
screams a second
meaning that this back and forth motion
of the tiny bones in the bat's ear
moves more than 200 times a second and
it's always in perfect alignment and
sending out these super short screams
now friends did you know that the bible
speaks of people who
like the bats are hearing but do not
hear spiritually speaking
in matthew 13 verse 13 jesus said
therefore i speak to them in parables
because
seeing they do not see and hearing they
do not hear
like the bat these people are able to
disconnect their spiritual ear from
hearing the promptings of the holy
spirit
it's like the person who continually
hits the snooze button on their alarm
clock until he conditions himself not to
wake up when the alarm rings
if a person keeps disregarding the
promptings of the holy spirit the day
will come when that person will no
longer hear the holy spirit speaking to
his heart through his conscience
that is what the bible refers to as the
unpardonable son or the sin against the
holy spirit
matthew 12 31 says therefore i say unto
you all manner of sin and blasphemy
shall be forgiven them but the blasphemy
against the holy ghost shall not be
forgiven them
no because they've disconnected their
spiritual ears so to speak from hearing
the holy spirit friends we have a study
guide it's called no turning back
we get questions that people ask what is
the unpardonable son some folks might
even be wondering if they've committed
the unpardonable sin well our study
guide will answer these questions it's
called no turning back and if you'd like
to receive it all you'll need to do is
call the number eight hundred eight
three five
six seven four seven you can ask for
offer number one
four six and we'll be happy to send that
to anyone who calls and asks
that number again is 800-835-6747
ask for the study guide no turning back
and we'll be happy to get in the mail
and send it out to you this is a live
interactive international bible study
pastor doug batchelor is out this
evening but we are live a new year happy
new year to all of those who are
listening and what a great way to start
a new year in studying the word of god
maybe you have bible questions maybe
there's a passage of scripture that
you've come across in your bible reading
plan if you started a bible reading plan
for this year
and you're wondering about what that
verse might mean well give us a call the
number to call here to the studio is
800-463-7297
again that number is 800 463 7297
we're live so we get ready to take your
bible questions i've got my
computer here in front of me with my
bible software and together we will
study the word of god but before we get
to the phone lines we always like to
begin with the word of prayer of course
the bible is god's book so we need the
holy spirit to understand it so let's
pray dear father we thank you that we
once again have this opportunity to open
up your word and study and father we ask
a blessing on this program there are
people who are watching people who are
listening across the country and even in
some other countries around the world
and lord together lead us into a clearer
and a full understanding of bible truth
for we ask this in jesus name amen
we're gonna go to the phone lines our
first caller this evening is john
listening in north carolina john welcome
to the program
good evening pastor ross good evening
yes my question is a bit nuanced but i
will attempt to make it as brief as i
can
the law of god existed before man's
creation is and is eternal but the
fourth commandment seems to be
exclusively connected with the creation
of this world
the last verse of the fourth commandment
says exodus 20 verse 11 for in six days
the lord made heaven and earth the sea
and all that in them is and rested the
seventh day wherefore the lord blessed
the sabbath day and hallowed it
um my question is this
if the law of god is eternal and i've
always believed it to be eternal from my
study myself um
why is the fourth seems like the fourth
commandment was instituted during the
creation of the world i'm wondering if
the law of god is eternal and the
sabbath was instituted during the
creation
is there a contradiction there or am i
missing something i just wanted to know
your guys thoughts on that okay great
question thank you john yes i agree with
you the law of god or the ten
commandments define what righteousness
is and what sin is sin is the
transgression of the law
now in order for there to be sin there
needs to be a law and we know that satan
sinned in heaven and then this sin this
rebellion started here on earth when
adam and eve gave in to satan's
temptation so the law must have existed
before
creation the principle that we find in
the fourth commandment which is the
sabbath commandment says remember the
sabbath day to keep it holy six days you
are to lay into all your work but the
seventh is the sabbath of the lord thy
god and then it says verse 11 for in six
days this is exodus 20 verse 11 for in
six days the lord made the heavens the
earth the sea and all that's in them and
he rested on the seventh day therefore
the lord blessed the sabbath day and
hallowed it so the sabbath is a
continual reminder that god is our
creator now it relates in a special
sense to
humanity i mean we're the ones that were
created in
on this earth we were created on the
sixth day of creation and the sabbath is
continually reminded that god is our
creator but not only are we created
beings but angels are created beings all
intelligent life is created and the
principle that we find of the fourth
commandment that of remembering our
creator and worshiping him and setting
aside a time to do so i think that
principle is true throughout the
universe now i don't know whether they
keep the same
day the seventh day the way we do as a
memorial but i'm sure there is the
recognition of a certain time throughout
the universe where all created beings
acknowledged that god is the creator a
special time that is being set aside for
worship now we know from the bible that
the seventh-day sabbath will continue
even after the earth is being recreated
in revelation chapter 21 you read about
a new heavens and a new earth isaiah
says from one sabbath to another all
will come and worship before god
so the little earth becomes if you like
the center of the universe because the
new jerusalem comes down and this is
going to be god's dwelling place and the
seventh-day sabbath will still be kept
in the earth made new so yes the
principle of worshiping god on a certain
time i think is relevant and that's true
for all created beings
does that help john
yes thank you so much pastor ross i
appreciate it all right thanks for your
call we appreciate it next caller that
we have is charles listening from
let's see calif well know charles is in
florida charles welcome to the program
hey pastor ross how are you doing well
thank you
my question is this um in my studies um
i've come across the
constellation of orion is mentioned
three times in job nine verse nine
uh chapter 38 verse 31
and in amos
uh chapter five verse eight my question
is this
is it possible that the god is somewhere
located somewhere through the nebula of
orion because even though
it talks about it
in levels three times i mean isn't that
possibly a hint that that's where he
resides somewhere through there well
that's a good question you know the
bible doesn't clearly say that heaven or
the dwelling place of god is
um there in orion but we do know as
mentioned three times as you mentioned
in scripture we do know that orion is to
the east uh you can see both the
constellation of orion sometimes
referred to as orion's belt
the the star uh constellation you can
see it both in the northern hemisphere
and the southern hemisphere now some of
the stars you can only see in the
southern hemisphere like the southern
cross and of course
the big dipper you can see in the
northern hemisphere you don't see that
in the southern hemisphere but orion is
close enough to the equator that it can
be seen both from the southern and the
northern hemisphere and it's to the east
we know in the bible that deliverance
symbolically comes from the east east is
the sign of deliverance or the dwelling
place of god for example deliverance for
the jews when they're in babylonian
captivity came from the east we had the
media persians came and conquered the
babylonians and the jews were allowed to
go back and rebuild
jerusalem
jesus speaking of his second coming says
there's lightning that flashes from the
east even to the west so also shall the
coming of the son of man be in
revelation chapter 7 an angel is seen
coming from the east having the seal of
the living god and he placed it upon the
forehead of those of god's people so the
east seems to be the direction of
deliverance it could very well be the
direction of heaven and yes orion is in
that
in that easterly direction so yes there
are a number of bible scholars that
think that orion at least near haran
would be
where the dwelling place of god is uh
known today as heaven we'd refer to it
as heaven
does that help charles awesome
absolutely absolutely
i've always wondered about that yes i
think i think you're on track there that
seems like there is something special
about orion as being close to the
dwelling place of god
all right thanks again for your call our
next caller that we have is emmanuel
calling from ghana africa emmanuel
welcome to the program
thank you pastor ross uh i hope pastor
doug is now around
yeah pastor dick is out today he's out
of town but he's doing well so he'll be
back next week okay
okay my greetings to him well my
question is in matthew chapter 23 verse
okay um jesus was
jesus was rebooting the authorities
concerning tithe
so i want to know that
this is trying to abolish tightening at
all
okay let me keep promoting that yes let
me read the verse for those who might
not have their bibles in front of them
matthew 23 verse 23 these are the words
of jesus woe to you scribes and
pharisees you hypocrites for you pay
tithe of mint
and anise and cumin these are little
spices and herbs and you have neglected
the weightier matters of the law justice
and mercy and faith
these you ought to have done without
leaving the others undone so here we
find jesus referring to the to the
scribes and the pharisees being so
meticulous in their tithe paying even on
their herb garden
and yet they were leaving out the more
important matters of the law that being
justice mercy and faith jesus says you
should be paying your tithe he says you
these you ought to have done
but not leave out the others the weight
here matters so when it comes to the
christian yes tithing is a biblical
principle we find it in the old
testament abraham is referred to as
giving a tithe to melchizedek and of
course this is a long time before moses
and the principle of tithing we also
find even in the new testament where
the early christians were giving more
than just a tenth to support the work of
the lord so faithful tithes and
offerings is found throughout scripture
jesus is not doing away with tithe but
rather he says tithe is important but
there are more important things that
being justice and mercy and faith those
are the things god also wants us to
remember does that help emanuel
yes
i'm okay thank you all right thanks for
your call we appreciate it you know we
do have a study guide that talks about
the christian and
their finances or tithing and offerings
what does the bible say about it it's
called in god we trust it's one of the
amazing facts study guides we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who just
calls and asks the number to call is 800
800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for the study
guide it's called in god we trust we'll
be happy to send it out we've got martha
listening in california martha welcome
to the program
hi thank you pastor ross um and happy
new year to you thank you thank you
thank you now i know that the bible does
not
contradict itself
um
and so i've run up against something i'm
either missing something
or i'm
misunderstanding something
uh in uh
let's see um in ezekiel 1820
and in deuteronomy 24 16
it talks about how
the father will not be punished for the
sins of the son the son will not be
punished for the sins of the father
and then
in
first samuel 28 18 and 19
there's
apparition shall we say that the witch
of endor has called up for um
saul
is telling saul that
um
the lord is angry with him because
he didn't do away with um
amalek and you know follow the other
directions and stuff and it says
moreover the lord will also deliver
israel with thee into the hand of the
philistines and tomorrow shalt thou and
thy sons be with me the lord also also
shall deliver
the host
of israel into the hands of the
philistines
so
i had thought that jonathan was
um
know a good man or whatever i don't know
anything about the other sons but i'm
wondering why
or could you explain this for me sure
absolutely now it's true there is a
biblical principle that the son is not
to bear the punishment of the father's
sin however sometimes there are
consequences that children do bear
because of the sins of their parents and
of course that's even true today
a lot of children go through
difficult childhoods
because of some abuse from a parent
well back in bible times you have soul
who's the king and he had pretty much
hardened his heart against the holy
spirit
and the holy spirit left him and he was
plagued by an evil spirit
there is this battle to take place and
saul was going to lead his army into
battle
uh well the sons of saul
wanted to be faithful not only to their
father but also to the nation of israel
and part of their responsibilities as
being princes as the sons of the king
was to accompany their father into
battle
now the reason they were slain in the
battle wasn't because of any sin they
had done but there were many good people
bible times that were killed in battles
but in this case you have jonathan who
is a very good man who
stood by the side of his father willing
to go to battle
even knowing that there is a very good
chance that
he might die in battle yet he stood
faithful it was not only for his father
but for the jewish nation as a whole to
encourage the jewish people and for his
god he believed in god and he believed
that god was directing
even though saul had hardened his heart
against the spirit of god he was still
the king at the time
and so jonathan was willing to do what
his father was asking to do in that
sense so it was not a judgment because
of his sin
that jonathan died in battle for saul
yes absolutely but not for jonathan
right okay well that helps a lot thank
you pastor ross i really appreciate it
all right thanks for cool martha next
quarter that we have is jess listening
in washington jess welcome to the
program
hello professor ross hello
i have a question it might seem silly
but
i read this and it really struck me so
i'm going to read it it's um
when moses
came to the burning bush
okay and uh
the lord said to him
take those shoes from off my feet
when the place that stannis is holding
and uh
but over here in joshua
joshua chapter five
angel the captain of the house
approached him and he tells him to take
his shoe
from off his foot
he doesn't say his shoes from off his
feet yes it says shoe off your foot
one now stannis is holding and i was
just gonna ask the question maybe joshua
might have lost one of his feet one
battle or something
no we have no record of josh joshua had
lost a foot in battle i just think the
the phrase there whether it's talking
about your foot or your
your feet
the principle there is the removing of
your shoes or the coverings of your feet
your sandals and that was a custom back
in bible times to show respect and
reverence
now the reason god said to moses take
the sandals off your feet for your
standing on holy ground that's because
the presence of god was there the great
i am god was in the burning bush this
angel that met joshua wasn't an angelic
being as you think of angels in heaven
but the word angel simply means a
messenger of the lord and in this case
the reason the angel the messenger says
take the sandal off your feet
because the place where you're standing
is holy ground uh it's referring to the
fact that this is actually joshua
meeting the lord and for that reason he
was to remove his sandals of from his
feet don't worry about the plural and
the singular it doesn't mean that joshua
was was hopping on one foot it's just
the way that it's worded there in the
in the english from the translation from
the hebrew but now joshua had both feet
because he was a mighty man of valor and
he led the army in battle
okay
yeah
good observation there in your study
uh mentions over here in deuteronomy 11
24 also that when moses was addressing
the people he said
every place where on the souls of your
feet shall tread shall be yours
yes yep okay
just a question i had yeah no that's a
great little point i've never noticed
that but yes don't worry about the
singular and plural there it's just
meaning the same thing when um they were
to enter into the presence of god they
were to remove their shoes you know that
custom is still in the middle east i've
traveled to india a number of times and
as a sign of respect when people enter
into the church into a place of worship
they remove their shoes from their feet
as you go into the main entry of a
church
i guess it's true even of the temples
there there's usually a pile of shoes
placed to the side and the people going
they remove their shoe as a sign of
respect and reverence so that was the
custom even in bible times in the middle
east thanks for call we got uh let's see
michael is listening from michigan
michael welcome to the program
yes hi uh pastor ross thanks for taking
my call sure
my question is about daniel 6 26 yes
uh is the king darius making a decree
that all men tremble and fear god his
kingdom and his dominion or is he saying
that god's kingdom and dominion will
last unto the end without being
destroyed
and also
do you see that these two kingdoms of
daniel 6 26 are contemporaneous
all right well let's take the first part
of the question is so when we have
king darius or darius writing this
decree this is after daniel is rescued
from the lion's den as you read about
there in daniel chapter 6.
the king is amazed because the god of
daniel which he knew about the god of it
daniel was able to shut the light the
mouths of the lions daniel came out
unscathed we know the lions were hungry
because those who had plotted against
daniel they were thrown in the lion's
den and it says they were devoured and
torn to pieces before they even hit the
ground so it was a miracle god was
taking care of his faithful servant
daniel the king acknowledged that and so
he made a decree and says
to every people nation language that
dwell on the earth of course at the time
darius was king of what they considered
the the whole the world at least the
known areas
and he says i make a decree that every
dominion of my kingdom men must tremble
and fear before the god of daniel in
other words they need to respect the god
of daniel the hebrew god for he is the
living god the steadfast forever his
kingdom is one that shall not be
destroyed his dominion shall endure
forever so here darius even acknowledges
that the kingdom of god is the true
eternal kingdom so daniel must have
explained something to him remember in
daniel chapter 2
nebuchadnezzar had a dream of these
various kingdoms coming and going and
it's very possible that daniel told
darius about what had happened to
nebuchadnezzar and that the rise of
media persia was a fulfillment of that
dream that was given in daniel 2 and
then ultimately in daniel 2 you have the
stone that strikes the image
and then it grows into a great mountain
fills the whole earth and that
symbolizes
the eternal kingdom that is established
after the second coming of christ so
darius understood this based on what
daniel had said and that's why he said
the god of the hebrew or daniel's god
his kingdom is an everlasting kingdom
does that have michael
well i'm wondering um
if this kingdom is of god here is the
same one that was uh
uh brought to nebuchadnezzar's attention
in daniel 2 44. yes i believe it is
because daniel must have told darius
about that and um
the fulfillment of daniel 2 at least the
second empire or second kingdom was mida
persia darius is king of the persians
now it was really a fulfillment of that
prophecy that had been given so after
persia was to come greece and then rome
and then western europe as we have it
now and then finally the second coming
of christ and so darius was aware of
that and that's why he said this god's
kingdom will last forever speaking of
daniel's god
yeah it sounds like like to me that this
this kingdom that he's speaking of is uh
currently
contemporaneous with his
kingdom yes well it's true too i mean
there are two parts of the kingdom of
god or the kingdom of heaven you know
when jesus started his ministry he said
repent for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand john the baptist said repent for
the kingdom of heaven is at hand there
are two phases to the kingdom of god
there is what we call the kingdom of
grace
and the kingdom of glory so the kingdom
of grace is for anyone who receives
jesus as their savior they become
citizens of the kingdom of grace if
christ is ruling in your heart in your
life you're a citizen of the kingdom of
grace
the kingdom of grace continues up until
the second coming of christ and then we
have the establishment of the kingdom of
glory when jesus comes as king of kings
and lord of lords so yes is there a
kingdom of heaven now absolutely we call
that the kingdom of grace the kingdom of
grace will eventually give way to the
kingdom of glory that occurs at the
second coming of christ and of course we
read that in revelation chapter 19 where
we have a picture of jesus symbolically
christ is described in revelation 19 as
coming on a white horse
of course kings and
empress would often ride on white horses
being victorious here jesus described
his coming and there is a name written
on his thigh which says king of kings
and lord of lords so jesus is coming
victorious to
establish a kingdom that lasts forever
that kingdom was also alluded to in
daniel chapter 2 by the stone that
struck the image upon its feet so that's
really what's been referred to there in
that passage does that does that make
sense michael
oh yeah kind of
so yes there are two kingdoms the
kingdom of grace and the kingdom of
glory
i'm wondering if the kingdom of uh 244
is contemporaneous with nebuchadnezzar
meaning the kingdom of heaven at that
same time
yeah yes the kingdom of heaven has
always been there's always been the
kingdom of heaven
and uh one that was established
yes and that was established it probably
established that the promise that was
made
way back in the garden of eden about the
seed of the woman that would bruise the
serpent's head
the kingdom of grace was established way
back then and pointed to jesus
and then when christ came he announced
the arrival of that kingdom of grace and
of course at the second coming you have
the kingdom of glory great question
enjoy the studies of the book of daniel
there's so many wonderful things there
and you know these prophecies that we
find in daniel really point to us
the trustworthiness of the scriptures
the bible is inspired because what was
said in old testament times we find a
fulfillment well friends we're up
halfway through our program we're just
taking a short break and we'll be right
back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
amazing facts offer some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
roger moore know shares his inspiring
journey from being caught up in the
terrifying world of the occult to his
rescue through divine intervention
get yours today by calling 800-538-720
or visit afbookstore.com
hello friends pastor doug batchelor here
with amazing facts
when susan's and michael's whirlwind
relationship led to a wedding they had
no idea how hard married life could be
before they knew it
they were on the stormy path towards
divorce
but that's when god led them to an
amazing facts broadcast
and there they saw the biblical view of
marriage as presented in knowing jesus
finally they understood what it meant to
love sacrificially like christ and today
susan and michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
michael and susan your simple investment
of faith and amazing facts will keep
growing in reaching more people with
god's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know christ
and the wonderful truth that you've
learned and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877-506-1751
the number again
877-506-1751
or just visit give.amazingfacts.org
or send your gift to p.o box 1058
roseville california 95678
thank you for tuning in to bible answers
live and don't forget to share with
others the amazing bible facts you have
learned here today
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back this is
pastor jean ross pastor doug is out this
evening but you've joined bible answers
live if you're just tuning in halfway
through the program this is a live
international interactive bible study
and we are so glad that you have found
us and you have tuned in i'd also like
to greet those who tune in every week i
know we have a number of faithful
listeners out there whether they're
listening on the radio watching on the
internet perhaps you're watching on
amazing facts television i want to
welcome all of you once again to our
program we have the next 30 minutes
where we're going to be taking your
bible questions so if you have a bible
related question the number to call here
to the studio is
800-463-7297 that again is
800-463-7297 that'll bring your call
here into the studio we're going to try
to answer as many questions as we can in
the next half an hour so we're going to
start by going to steve in michigan
steve welcome to the program
hello good evening duff uh pastor ross
good evening
um i have a question when it concerns
what the bible says about
people judging people the first uh entry
is is matthew 7 1
actually versus after where it says
judge
lest ye be judged and talks goes on to
talk about removing the plank of your
own eye before you remove the the
splinter out of your brother's eye
and the there's another passage also in
john 7 24 where it talks at the end of
that verse it says judge correctly
could you kind of give the context of
both of those entries and how to
reconcile
uh those those two uh
those two versions yeah absolutely great
question uh first of all just for those
who might not have their bibles in front
of them they might be driving their car
listening on the radio the verse you're
referring to there is matthew chapter 7
verse 1 where jesus says judge not
that you be not judged now i think next
to john 3 16 this is probably one of the
most well-known verses out there in the
world people are often
willing to say judge not because you
know they might be doing something that
they know is not right
jesus goes on in verse two he says for
with whatever judgment you judge you
will be judged and whatever measure you
use it'll be measured back to you so
christ says do not judge but then later
on you bring out in matthew chapter 7
the same the same chapter
here jesus says that we are to judge
wisely or rightly
and you also find in verse 15 jesus says
beware of false prophets who come to you
in sheep's clothing but inwardly are
ravenous wolves you will know them by
their fruits
so on the one hand we are not to judge
but on the other hand we are to consider
the fruits that a person might produce
in their life
their actions and we need to determine
whether they are true or whether they
are false so here's the point we want to
bear in mind
we do not know the motive of the heart
only god knows the heart and when it
comes to us judging why
someone might do something or judging
their heart or their motive
we can't do that only god knows the
heart he knows the reason but that
doesn't mean that god has not
revealed to us what is right and wrong
we should be able to know or at least to
discern
if somebody is doing something that is
contrary to the will of god or contrary
to the word of god or if in the church
someone might be preaching that which is
contrary to the word of god we need to
be able to distinguish and in a sense
judge between
the actions or the life versus the
profession but that's different from
judging the motive or judging whether
somebody is saved or lost that's only
something that god can do
we don't know the heart only god knows
the heart but we should be able to tell
by the actions whether someone is
genuine or whether they counterfeit
does that help steve
well yes now the part where it says
in um
in uh john 7 24 it says judge correctly
how do does that basically pertain to
counseling the person also yes that can
involve counseling the person judged
correctly it can also involve in the
context here jesus is talking about
false teachers or false prophets those
who are claiming to be the followers of
christ
but they are
they are teaching or preaching error and
they're misleading people and the bible
says judge correctly be careful
uh not every church is necessarily the
true church not every preacher or
teacher is necessarily
preaching the truth and we need to have
spiritual discernment so in that sense
there is a judging but it's not judging
the motive we don't know the motive but
we should be able to judge the words and
the actions to know if it's right or
wrong
okay well thank you very much all right
great appreciate your call next quarter
that we have is eric calling from
georgia eric welcome to the program
thank you pastor ross
thank you for calling
yes
my question is um
i have a question is first timothy
chapter two verse nine okay what do you
say about this
all right let me read it for those who
might not have their bibles in front of
them timothy is writing to the church
and he says in like nano also that women
adorn themselves in modest apparel with
propriety and moderation not with
braided hair or gold or pearls or costly
clothing but that which is proper for
women professing godliness with good
works
so your question on this verse is um is
it good for women
so does it mean that women shouldn't
wear
getting their hair braids and you know
wearing
gold necklace and purse and stuff like
that which is not
good for women or okay well you raise a
good question the bible is clear that
christians both men and women need to
look different from the world they need
to dress modestly that doesn't mean that
they have to wear clothes that is too
big or
old-fashioned or you know out of style
but within
within our culture we want to dress
model address
modestly
and also not allow
the outward adorning to be prevalent
meaning the wearing of gold and
and silver and and jewels and costly
array now when it says the braiding of
the hair back in bible times what the
womb would do is they would actually
weave in bits of jewelry into their
braids into their hair
there's nothing wrong in a woman holding
back her hair or braiding her hair for
practical purposes to keep it out of her
face if she's working or whatever the
case might be there's nothing wrong with
that but the braiding of the hair that's
referred to here was a type of braiding
of adornment or gold or silver or the
jewels in their hair and that's
specifically what he's been referred to
hearing first timothy chapter two verse
nine so yes the principle that we find
there is that
both for christian woman and for men we
need to dress modestly
and not be bedecked with gold and silver
and jewels
but rather allow as the bible says in
the next verse
those professing godliness allow the
spirit to come through
and may a person not be attracted to
outward adorning so that's the principle
you know we do have a book that talks
about this
it's something that you don't hear a
whole lot about especially in modern
churches today but the bible hasn't
changed on these christian standards
uh we have a book called jewelry how
much is too much and it deals with these
bible principles we'll be happy to send
this out to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call is 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the book it's
called jewelry how much is too much and
it'll give you some good bible
principles there next caller that we
have is may listening in washington may
welcome to the program
hi pastor ross um
can you hear me i can
okay sorry
um i just wanted to um ask about
genesis 9 verses 25 okay um we see here
that noah
was i guess he was
drunk or
he was pretty wasted from the um wine
that he drank and
he curses his grandson but not the son
that
not ham that
saw him naked
yeah let me explain that a little bit
why
okay why canaan was cursed well you know
back uh
at the time you have
ham sham ham and japheth all the three
sons of noah
after the flood noah builds or grows a
vineyard and he he makes wine and he
drinks it and he's drunk
and a ham comes in and mocks his father
and tells his brothers so shame and
japheth
they cover the father and they show
respect they honor the father whereas
ham doesn't
and after noah sort of comes around he
realizes what ham had done in mocking
him
and he makes a prophecy he makes a
statement and the statement is that
because
ham and his son canaan and his
descendants
lacked respect and they disobeyed the
commandment that says honor your mother
and your father
judgments would follow
it doesn't mean that
kanan per se even though you probably
knew what what had happened with his
father he shared the same attributes or
the same rebellion that ham manifest
towards noah that was also something
that canaan had also
harbored in his heart and that's why the
curse comes
against canaan and anyone that holds to
that rebellious spirit no matter what
their ancestry is
those who refuse to keep god's
commandments those who refuse to honor
their parents
yeah they're they're bringing upon them
so they self-judgment the problem the
promise that we have of that commandment
that says honor your mother and your
father that your days may be long in the
land that the lord that god gives you
there's practical benefits and blessings
to those who honor their parents here on
the earth and that's the principle
that's been emphasized there in genesis
does that oh wow does that help that
makes more sense no yeah because i'm
actually starting to read the bible good
well it's a good time to do so
yeah the beginning of a new year
right right
all right well thanks for your call mate
we appreciate it so much all right
bye-bye bye
next quarter that we have is uh danny in
arizona danny welcome to the program
good good evening pastor ruff hi uh
happy new year thank you and to you
awesome thank you have a question so um
so the lord he uh he created
lucifer names angels before the earth
correct yes
okay all right so
my question was um because we know that
he cast down satan and then he deceived
the world and stuff like that um
did god
have to create
humans in order to fulfill
the justice of getting rid of satan in
the end
no i you know first of all we know that
sin is not something that god
is wanting uh sin is contrary to him god
is a god of love the bible is very clear
that god is god love he doesn't want any
of his creatures to suffer
sin
suffering and death is clearly
the results of satan's rebellion it
comes from disobedience to god when
somebody disobeys god in essence they
are separating themselves from the
source of happiness from the source of
life
and if you're separating yourself from
happiness and the source of life and the
source of peace you're going to end up
with unhappiness and you end up with
sorrow and you're going to end up with
death so that's just the natural
consequences of being separated from god
now god also
can only because he's a god of love he
can only accept the worship of
intelligent beings
when those beings do so
willingly god can accept worship that is
not freely and willingly given thus
freedom
is highly esteemed in heaven god gives
all intelligent beings freedom
we have freedom we can choose to serve
him we can choose not to serve him the
angels have that same freedom they could
choose to obey god or they could choose
to disobey god now there are
consequences to disobeying god because
if you're separating yourself from god
as i mentioned there is sorrow and
suffering and death adam and eve they
were given those same
opportunities they could have chosen
to stay loyal to god
but unfortunately they listened to the
lies of satan and they chose a different
master
and when they listened to the devil
sorrow and suffering and death came but
the amazing part of the story is that
god did not abandon adam and eve even
though he told them and he warned them
when they sinned he came and he said you
know i'm gonna make a way of escape i am
going to bear your sins
and i'm going to die in your place jesus
was promised to come
and so that we can be forgiven so that
we can live forever so despite sin
god has got a plan of redemption to save
us
and that's that's another revelation of
his love
i understood okay awesome well thank you
very much yeah great question thank you
danny thanks for calling next quarter
that we have is roy listening from uh
new york roy welcome to the program
good evening pastor and how are you
doing well thank you and yourself
i praise the lord i'm doing good i'm
doing good
and your question tonight okay
yeah my question is from uh
first timothy chapter four
uh
you know i i know formerly that god's
word is true and that it does not
contradict itself
um i'm reading from uh verses three and
four it says
uh
it says forbidden to marry and command
them to abstain from meat which god had
created to be received with thanksgiving
of them which believe and know the truth
for verse 4 says for every creature of
god is good and nothing to be refused if
it be received with thanksgiving
now um this is a verse that
many people use to support their
argument that everything was created
you know for us to eat and i know that
can't be true
okay especially um when i consider
leviticus chapter 11 yes i'm asking if
you can explain that sure we'll be happy
to uh let me give you the context of
this if you look in verse 1 it says this
is paul writing and he says the spirit
expressly says that in the latter times
meaning
the times of the end which we're living
in there will be those who depart from
the faith and then it gives us some
identifying marks of those who depart
from the faith he says they speak lies
in hypocrisy they have their conscience
seared with a hot iron they forbid to
marry they command to abstain from
certain foods that god has created to be
received for thanksgiving so he's
talking about a religious movement in
the last days
where part of the teachings of the
doctrines of this movement says that
well if you
part of the clergy you can't marry
and there are certain days when you
can't eat certain foods
now it's not saying here that unclean
foods
are good to eat because you look in
verse 4 it says every creature of god is
good nothing to be refused if it is
received with thanksgiving but the very
next verse says in verse 5 for it is
sanctified by the word of god in prayer
the word sanctify means set apart
so does the word of god set apart
certain foods
that you can eat meaning certain meats
and certain meats that you can't eat
yes it does there are clean meats and
there are unclean meats the clean meats
yes they can be received there was this
religious movement that was saying
there's certain clean foods or certain
clean meats you can't eat and that's
really what paul is addressing here
verse 5 clearly tells us that it must be
sanctified by the word of god meaning it
has to be set apart by the word of god
in order to be acceptable in order for
it to be good so we can't leave out
verse five it gives context to verse
four okay yeah praise the lord thank you
very much pasta oh you're welcome thanks
for calling appreciate it
next caller that we have is calling from
um
zeal from north carolina zeal welcome to
the program
hey pastor russ thank you for taking my
call you're welcome
uh yes i just had a question
so
um
i'd like to go out and do um
how do you say um
spread the gospel
and then i've come across a few that
believe that we're gonna continue
standing until jesus comes okay so
how can i respond to that like how can i
you know what will be the the answer for
that well you know i think it's true
that yes we live in a world where there
is sin and uh there are victories to
gain and i don't think you can ever
get to the point where you think that
somehow you are free from temptation as
long as we live in this world we're
going to be tempted and there's always
the potential for sin
but that doesn't mean that we have to be
bound by sin meaning we don't have to be
controlled by sinful
propensities or selfish sinful desires
the bible says jesus says if the son
sets you free you shall be free indeed
now that's a promise we all struggle
with sin we're all selfish by nature
and we have this
this flesh the paul speaks about the
carnal nature
and yes we need to fight against that
carnal nature in our own strength it is
impossible for us to overcome but with
god the bible says all things are
possible and you know in my ministry in
my experience i have met people who have
gained incredible victories
by god's grace in their life people who
have gained victory over
alcohol tobacco drugs
over
bad relationships over stealing or
cursing i mean you just name any of the
ten commandments
i can point to examples of people who
god has delivered
they've been empowered by the spirit of
god they have overcome
that's good news so we don't have to be
in bondage to sin christ is able to set
us free so we want to encourage people
not only to the gospel tell us that we
can be forgiven
but the gospel also gives us the power
to obey and that comes by faith the
bible says the just shall live by faith
and so if we can encourage people to
look to jesus as not only the one who
forgives but the one who empowers and
sustains
they will be able to grow spiritually
and actually in their own experience
experience victory and that really is
inspiring for every person that's what
god wants us to have and that is to have
victory does that um does that make
sense azil
thank you pastor appreciate it you know
we do have a book it's called is it
possible to live without sinning and
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks the number is simply
800-835-6747 after the book called is it
possible to live without sinning don't
be afraid of the title uh yes you can be
victorious friends the bible doesn't
want you to be bound by sinful um
you know chained to sin no jesus can set
us free doesn't mean we'll never sin or
make a mistake but we don't have to be
controlled by this habitual sense all
right johnny's calling from georgia john
welcome to the program
how you doing pastor doing well thanks
oh yes sir
my question was uh what is the
significance of fasting when we pray uh
how does god view fasting what does it
do
uh to open up
that connection with the father okay
what is the important significance of
fasting you know what fasting does is
sets aside just something that all of us
experience that is hunger and we all
need food
but it's when we set that aside for a
period of time in essence we are
focusing our attention away from
ourselves saying lord there is something
more important
my relationship with you
having you hear my prayer i am trusting
in you to answer my prayer it is so
important that i do that which is
pleasing to you that i'm willing to set
aside my food i'm willing to fast
it's not that we win merit with god
because god is a god of love we can't
earn his favor
but when we set aside food and we go
into fasting and there's different types
of fasting sometimes fasting might be
just setting aside
a certain food that you might
particularly like it might not be bad in
of itself but you set it aside and say
you know i'm going to fast for a week or
so and not eat this dessert or whatever
the food might be
i'm gonna focus on prayer and i'm gonna
i'm gonna earnestly seek
god through prayer and it's
acknowledging that god is more important
than even our physical needs in the
bible we see examples of people who
fasted and they were faithful even to
the point of death saying lord i would
rather die they knowingly disobey you
they valued that relationship so much
daniel prayed three times a day he
opened the windows and he prayed even
though he knew there was a death decree
for anyone who would pray to the god of
heaven but he valued that communication
with god even more
than his life so that's the principle
that we see there in fasting where we
set something aside we'll be saying lord
i'm coming to you
you're more important than even my
physical needs
does that help john
yes sir is there a time limit uh the job
requires of uh no
no usually what happens is you decide
and you know it might just be skipping
uh two meals or a meal or uh uh one or
two days there are different types of
fast depends upon the circumstances and
the urgency of the prayer uh if there's
something really important and you
you're pleading with the lord you need
an answer
uh you might want to fast a little bit
longer but those are things that you
allow the holy spirit to really convict
you of
and some people just make it a part of
their routine once a week they'll fast
skip a couple of meals or maybe fast for
one day and say i'm going to set aside
this day
to turn my attention to the lord and to
seek his presence in prayer and that's a
good thing
that's something that um you know will
benefit us not only physically now maybe
not everyone can fast you might have low
blood sugar or a diabetic or something
like that but
for most people skipping a few meals is
probably a good thing so there's
physical benefits but of course also
spiritual when we set our focus upon god
all right well thanks again john for
your call good question the next caller
that we have is uh robert in washington
robert welcome to the program
yay i'm the last caller i guess huh you
might be yes and your question tonight
uh acts 17 verse 28 um
there's this one religion that believes
that we were
we were
alive before we were born kind of thing
and they were telling me about this one
verse that
uh in him we live and move and have our
being
as a as the poet has said
yes um
what is he talking about there yeah
absolutely can a person uh
use that verse to say that we were
before where you were
no i don't think so i mean the verse is
pretty clear it's just stating that in
him we live and move and have our being
meaning that god is the one that
sustains us and gives us life let me the
context here we have paul and he's
talking to a group of philosophers
and
they're very superstitious they had
multiple gods that they would worship
and there was a a shrine
to the unknown god so they felt as
though they needed to create the shrine
to a god that they didn't know lest they
offend him
and paul uses this as an opportunity to
present the gospel and so he starts on a
common ground he says well i've come to
make known unto you this unknown god
that you have and he begins to talk
about the god of heaven and when it
created all things and then he even
quotes from there
from their wise man yeah one of their
poets and he says and he quotes
the phrase for in him we live and move
and have our being well that's true with
reference to god
and he's building that bridge he's
making that connection but this is not
talking about the people living before
they were born it's just simply stating
the reality that our life
is because god has given it to us and he
sustains us in him we live we move we
have our being
we would not be here if it was not for
him so i don't think you can use this
verse to support predestined some sort
of
pre-existence
before being born or even reincarnation
after a person dies that's not what this
verse is referring to it's just stating
the reality so i think that's pretty
clear we are his offspring though
yes he made us we are created uh if god
did not create us we wouldn't be here
the bible sometimes refers to us as the
children of god or the sons or daughters
of god
so his offspring isn't isn't necessarily
mean
that
we were
not created we were created not the
other way around
yeah it's just stating that we were
created and we owe our existence to god
because he made us all things come from
him friends we're coming to the end of
our radio program but we will be back
for some more bible questions thank you
for listening to today's broadcast we
hope you understand your bible even
better than before bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
hello friends welcome back we have just
two minutes left and we're going to try
and take some of the questions that came
in via the internet some of the email
questions that you have sent in uh we
like in the next two minutes to try and
see how many questions we can answer so
here we go i'm going to just read
through these questions give you an
answer the first question is what bible
version do you recommend
well first of all i'd like to mention
when it comes to bible versions of bible
translations there are two different
categories you have a
paraphrase
and then you have a translation a
paraphrase would be somebody taking
maybe an english bible and then writing
the verses in a more contemporary
english or whatever language it might be
but it's not necessarily a direct
translation from the original languages
which should be hebrew and greek there's
a little bit of aramaic that you find
also there in the book of daniel
a translation is actually going to the
original manuscripts or the copies of
the original manuscripts and then
translating from that so when it comes
to bible study especially deep bible
study you want to make sure that you
have a trustworthy translation i like to
use the king james the new king james
new american standard version there are
a number of good translations out there
just remember that the bible wasn't
written in english it was written in
hebrew and greek and so if you want to
really get to a deeper meaning of the
word find a good concordance and you can
look up the original words there as well
and what they mean another question that
came and it says when i pray am i
supposed to pray to god or jesus
or do i pray to both of them
well jesus gave an example of prayer he
said when you pray say our father which
art in heaven hallowed be thy name so we
are to direct our prayers to our
heavenly father but we pray in the name
of jesus that's why when we end our
prayer we say in jesus name it's through
his merits that make our prayers
acceptable we know the holy spirit also
intercedes and actually brings to our
mind the very things that we need to
pray for
so we direct our prayers to god the
father in the name of jesus and we are
praying for the guidance and the leading
of the holy spirit another question that
somebody has is when is the time of
trouble and how do we prepare for it
well the bible speaks of a time of
trouble that will be worse than there
has ever been
since the beginning of time you read
that in daniel chapter 12 verse 1. well
that's talking about a time period and
the seven last plagues will be poured
out and that's after probation closes
how do we prepare for that well i think
we prepare by setting our heart towards
god that full surrender of self to jesus
and we do that every day we have to come
to god and ask him to cleanse us ask for
forgiveness
we need not fear because the bible
promises us that if we are christ when
that time of trouble comes he will keep
us secure and safe he will protect us so
we can trust in him we need not fear
friends thank you for joining us for
bible answers live look forward to
seeing you next week
[Music]
you